[Musica]
nel 2002 lavora i poco più di un anno al
centro di epidemiologia della regione
veneto
all'epoca faceva un dottorato di ricerca
in salute pubblica alla university of
california los angeles ma decisi di
prendere una pausa e tornare in italia
erano mesi produttivi anche se qualcuno
mi chiedeva
non ho ancora ben capito che lavoro fai
ad un certo punto nel centro
epidemiologico ci fu un cambiamento
nella leadership è il nuovo direttore un
medico comunicò che le mie competenze
professionali non servivano più ciao ne
fu curiosa l'argomentazione poiché
ancora oggi in italia non esiste una
scuola di salute pubblica ma forse anche
lui non aveva ben capito che lavoro
facevo oggi però vi parlo di una
pandemia che ha ucciso quasi 5 milioni
di persone
pensate a questi nomi ci vorrebbe quasi
un mese a leggerli tutti
spesso mi sono chiesto potevamo salvare
queste vite come alcuni pensano che sia
sia stato fatto il possibile
altri invece dicono che per fini
lockdown sono stati inutili
chi ha ragione hanno torto entrambi ma
non lo dico io lo dice l'epidemiologia
la scienza che studia la distribuzione
dei decessi e delle malattie a livello
di popolazione
l'epidemiologia una sorella che si
chiama salute pubblica impegnata a
prevenire malattie e prolungare la vita
attraverso sforzi organizzati della
società è un po come dire
se l'epidemiologia fa il conto dei morti
la salute pubblica fa in modo che questi
morti continu oggi vi parlerò dei cinque
errori letali e delle quattro azioni
vitali nella gestione della pandemia
inseguire al virus invece di anticiparlo
è stato il primo nostro errore
sappiamo da anni che un grammo di
prevenzione equivale un chilo di cura ma
quando è scoppiata la pandemia i nostri
piani pandemici non erano pronti
l'italia non aggiornava il suo da 14
anni e poi pochi anni prima era stato
soppresso il centro di epidemiologia
nazionale molti hanno descritto questa
pandemia come un cigno nero
un evento straordinario
imprevedibile
eppure molti studiosi ci avevano
avvertiti per loro ora assomiglia di più
a un cigno bianco un evento non solo
prevedibile ma previsto il secondo
errore la disinformazione abbiamo notato
esperti ed esperte e in questo abbiamo
raggiunto quasi la parità di genere
occupare le tv dicendo che il virus era
poco più di un influenza poi abbiamo
sentito esperti diffondere
l'idea che praticamente questa pandemia
fosse praticamente
che i dati di mortalità non fossero così
affidabili sono morti con o per
coronavirus poi abbiamo sentito sparate
il virus clinicamente morto emergenza
finita il terzo errore è stato aver
scambiato una pandemia per un problema
medico ma come non lo è forse
sì e no più no che sì una pandemia un
problema di salute pubblica e il virus
va affrontato sul territorio noi in
ospedale
pensate che uguale a un bravo clinico
che riesce a far bene il suo lavoro può
salvare le malattie di alcune persone ma
un esperto in prevenzione può salvare la
vita di migliaia di persone
il quarto errore è stato quello che ho
chiamato l'approccio la sefea il virus
se cullata l'illusione di proteggere
l'economia senza fare i conti con la
pandemia sacrificando vite umane
sull'altare di una falsa promessa
l'immunità di gregge ma salute o
economia è una falsa dicotomia il modo
migliore per proteggere le attività
produttive non è lasciar andare al virus
ma
combatterlo attraverso la prevenzione
è l'ultimo le iniquità sociali
abbiamo scambiato il salles co2 per un
virus democratico ma in realtà
all'evidenza dice l'esatto contrario i
meno abbienti hanno maggiore rischio di
decesso
ricovero e contagio
inoltre si è creato una specie di
apartheid vaccinale dove la maggior
parte dei paesi poveri non riusciranno a
immunizzare la maggioranza della loro
popolazione prima del 2024
questo è un grave problema
poiché può creare diffusione di varianti
e sapete il virus non riconosce i
confini geografici
nessuno sarà al sicuro finché tutti non
saranno al sicuro quindi che fare
premessa i vaccini sono molto efficaci
nel ridurre mortalità e ricoveri
tuttavia ciò che ha fatto davvero la
differenza nel salvare vite umane sono
state quattro azioni vitali testare
tracciare isolare in tempo
l'uso dei test di massa è stato un
caposaldo del successo dei paesi più
virtuosi quelli che hanno gestito meglio
la pandemia non a caso hanno i più bassi
indici di mortalità al mondo
affrontare invece una pandemia senza un
efficace piano tamponi è come andare in
guerra contro un nemico invisibile ma
testare tracciare
a tracciare scusate in italia c'è stato
il flop dell'app
ricordate immuni
eppure immuni poteva essere la
sentinella più potente nella lotta al
virus
un sistema di sorveglianza
epidemiologico
dati georeferenziati è essenziale per
far che cosa identificare focolai
maniera tempestiva e aggredirli con
interventi preventivi localizzati
inoltre è importante isolare i
contagiati
però le persone che si devono isolare
vanno aiutate anche economicamente
durante un'emergenza la solidarietà
economica fa la differenza uniti stiamo
in piedi divisi cadiamo diceva una
canzone dei pink floyd
nella caccia al virus la velocità è
tutto testare tracciare e isolare
perdono gran parte della loro efficacia
se non vengono fatti in maniera
tempestiva
pensate la nuova zelanda che ha avuto
solo 27 decessi e
adottato un lockdown consolo contagio
beh la zona zelanda un'isola direte voi
sì è un isolano cobit se queste azioni
letali ci permettono di affrontare
questa pandemia
cosa possiamo fare per prevenire la
prossima
gli scienziati si sono mobilitati per
studiare da dove deriva questo maledetto
virus è l'ipotesi più accreditata è che
abbia origini naturali ma a pensarci
bene non c'è nulla di naturale
in questa ipotesi
le maggiori cause del rischio pandemico
sono di natura antropica il consumo di
fauna selvatica la deforestazione
l'industrializzazione della produzione
animale l'urbanizzazione l'esplosione
demografica in viaggio internazionale e
il cambiamento climatico
ma alla base di questi fattori c'è un
sistema economico che antepone la
crescita economica infinita e il mercato
che si autoregola a qualsiasi altro
valore della società
questo modello di sviluppo è una
macchina delle pandemie
i critici visionari di riforme radicali
di questo modello di sviluppo vengono
tacciati di scarso realismo ma i veri
utopisti sono credi sono quelli che
credono di tornare alla normalità creare
un nuovo equilibrio tra persone nature
animali è l'antidoto più importante
contro future pandemie è la risposta
immunitaria umanitaria da instillare in
ognuno di noi
[Musica]